hey what's up this is john with the dr
john de loni show today we are talking
about
how to talk to a relative that you
didn't know existed
we're talking about should i get
divorced or should i stick it out
and we're talking about being married to
somebody with adhd
something my wife knows a lot about stay
tuned
what's up i am john and this is the dr
john deloney show
taking your calls about your life we're
talking about relationships your
relational iq
your marriages your parenting the slow
dumpster fire that is homeschooling in
millions of homes
the fact that that entire states seem to
be on fire there are hurricanes in the
gulf it's just a tough
time for everybody you know what we're
even going to talk about
maybe maybe the reply all people
they reply all people who thinks that
everyone cares that you're in
or i'm grateful or who just needs to see
your s
stupid thumbs up emoji don't reply all
unless you have to folks right we're
gonna be talking about all of it
so whatever's going on in your heart
whatever's going on in your mind
whatever's going on
in your home or your neighborhood give
me a call i'm here to walk with you
my number is 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or you can email me at
ask
john ramseysolutions.com leave your name
a message kelly's going to read those
emails and she will circle back and get
in touch with you
so i'm so excited to take your calls i'm
so excited to get your emails
and hey here's the deal shout out to
everybody we launched this podcast it
launched at number one it is remaining
way way up there it's outdoing all of
our expectations
i'm so grateful for the callers i'm so
grateful for the listeners
thank you so much we are all in this
together
and let's go right to the phones man
let's go to jeremy in atlanta
jeremy what is up my man dr d
huge fan thank you so much for taking my
call man i'm a fan of you brother how
can i help
all right so the ultimate question is um
i found that i have a sibling through
the miracles of ancestry dna
and i want to know how to navigate that
basically have i done
all i can do to foster that relationship
wow so you were just putting along on
the internets and
suddenly you've got a sibling tell me
about this well
all right so never knew who my dad was i
was raised by my grandparents
my mom was 15 when she had me there's a
whole nother backstory to that we won't
go there
um i have other siblings but i never
i didn't really meet them until i was
an adult um she has she had four
other kids and they grew up on the other
side of the country and all that stuff
so
i was raised as you know as an only
child so i didn't really know how to
have siblings and
i've got pretty good relationships with
the uh with the other siblings that my
mom had
but my dad who i never knew about is
um how we end up with this other sister
um and uh so she's
just two months younger than me and uh
she grew up just like 30 40 minutes away
from where i grew up which is kind of
wild
yeah and into each other type of thing
you know um
so two years ago um my wife talked me
into doing the ancestry thing
just to kind of see and um so it came
back that i have this
you know it says close relative it
doesn't really tell you how to like kind
of look through it
and it said half sister or aunt or
whatever it says and so i just reach out
and you know we start talking and
whatever and
and um and and things go great turns out
she was adopted
at birth so she never knew anybody
either um
she got her mother she got her
adoption records when she you know
turned 18 or so and
got in contact with her birth mom her
birth mom gave her information on her
father
um and she never just she just kind of
dropped it and didn't do anything with
it
and then so when i reached out we kind
of
went down that path together um and we
found out that he had died back in the
90s and
oh wow yeah like well we were still
teenagers
so man number one that's an incredible
story high five to your wife
for it's kind of wild right yeah i mean
you've got to
tie a bunch of loose ends that up until
just five or six or seven years ago most
people had to go through the rest of
their life being completely untethered
not knowing a lot about their family
history or where they're from
yeah so you've got to find out man more
about your history than most people
throughout the world have been able to
find out in your similar situation
and you've reconnected so how can i help
you with with where you're at right now
all right so that was two years ago and
we talked all the time we got caught up
we you know we discovered things about
our dad we tried to reach out to that
side of the family
they don't want anything to do with us
that's fine moved on from that
um but we live about a thousand miles
apart
my sister and i and she still lives up
by where you know we both grew up
and um and so anyway so
it was you know she's got a busy life
i've got a busy life but i still go
back home occasionally and the plan was
always to
you know meet up next time i was in the
area well i've been up there
i don't know four or five times now and
it's always yeah we'll do this we'll do
that
and when i get there it's nothing now i
don't go there just for her i go there
to see other people i have other reasons
to go there
but always it always falls through so
you all have never met in person
no we've never even talked on the phone
it's always been tested
or facebook message things like that
okay um
so jeremy can i can i acknowledge
something sure
um this sucks it's
it's weird for sure no hold on you're so
here's the deal you're a hardcore dude
you've had to put up with some crap in
your life um your dad abandoned you and
he shouldn't have
and evidently your mom is a saint and
you married well
and you must have done some hard work
cause you are a together guy
and the fact that you and
i'm just gonna lay it out and be direct
you called me right so we're gonna i'm
gonna lay it out
the fact that you reached out
made yourself vulnerable and somebody is
once again choosing to reject you dude
that sucks it shouldn't be like that and
i hate that for you
that's more than you know i mean that
dude that sucks
and i hate that for you um i appreciate
it
in in terms of like are you doing the
best you can
at some point you got to let it be what
it is
which is she doesn't want to hang out
with you don't want to talk to you and
so that's what i thought and then the
last time i was up there i i backed off
it i said you know what i'm sorry i
pushed this on you
that that's it i'm done we'll you know
we'll connect when you want to connect
or not
and that was i don't know oh 18
months or so ago maybe not quite and um
and then about a year ago now she was
like hey i'm going to be where you live
i'm going to be in atlanta let's hook up
cool
awesome clear my schedule all this stuff
and the time comes and
crickets nothing i don't get a call i
don't get a text until she's
back on the plane oh and there's some
other excuse whatever right
and we really other than like christmas
and birthdays we really
haven't had any conversation since then
and the conversation's only ever been my
text
jeremy that's what it's going to be
brother
yeah that's what it's going to be you
basically need to know from some you
know from somebody that hey
i've done all i can do and i can let
that part go
so listen doing all you can do
is whatever you decide it is there's a
point when you do too much
and that's when someone's got to come in
and draw a boundary on you
but the reality is men you've done a
noble thing which is to reach out i
think that's
i think it's a hard step again it's a
vulnerable step again because you don't
know
what you're reaching out into um and you
are wrestling with this fantasy
and it the the downside of being able to
connect with folks
that are from our past that otherwise
throughout history we never would have
known
there's an upside to it and i talked
about that at the beginning of this call
the downside is
man there's you don't know what you're
walking into and it becomes this
we're so desperate to be tethered to a
lineage
to be tethered to a legacy to be to know
our brothers and sisters
and to be known right to know that we're
not crazy out there
in the world just flapping in the wind
and
nobody should know us better than those
that share our dna
right our brothers and our sisters and
our half-brothers and our half-sisters
and it's so easy to get sucked into a
fantasy
which is we're gonna connect we're gonna
have this moment she's gonna look like
me i'm going to look a little bit like
her we're going to laugh the same
and then we're going to start having
christmases and thanksgivings together
and i'm going to be able to patchwork
this family back
this one that again man your dad left
you high and dry
you've had to deal with that pain
throughout your whole life you're going
to be able to stitch this sucker back
together and we're going to get to some
semblance of
of man and i hate to tell you this
jeremy it's
it doesn't look like it's going to
happen i can't imagine the pain and the
disconnection your sister is going
through so i'm not trying to put her on
blast it is what it is
but you've done a lot and i think you're
a gift
and i think that um you got to let the
fantasy go
and maybe one day out of the blue she
reaches out and i think when that
happens
you and your wife need to have talked
about what are our boundaries gonna be
are we gonna let somebody come live with
us are we gonna
not um are we gonna not
i don't know loan money or what is that
going to look like for us
but i think i think setting up those
boundaries ahead of time is smart but
man you've done what you can do
you've put it out there i wish there was
a nicer way to say this
she's rejected the opportunities to meet
both
you there and her here man i'd let that
right off into the sunset
i think a a birthday and christmas is a
good time to text
i think that's great um yeah so thanks
for the call jeremy man i'm just
rattling in my head what it would be
like and i i just know i'm somebody who
would
um golly i would struggle with that
because i want everyone to be whole i
want everyone to love me i want everyone
to be in a relationship with me
and it just sucks when someone's like
yeah let's super meet up and then they
don't
and then like yeah for sure for sure
this time we're gonna meet up and then
they don't then they don't
hey uh thank you so much jeremy let's go
to an email real quick
vladimir says i've heard you say that we
act on what we focus on
would you be able to elaborate on that
and possibly talk more in depth
as to how to change someone's focused
format
so i don't really know what a focused
format is vladimir but
i do like this idea this question here's
the deal
when we are struggling with what to do
we have default settings we have things
that we want to do in our life we have
goals that we want to achieve we have
things that we don't want to do in our
life
so much of the time we focused on
stopping stuff we don't love we focused
on
not doing other things right instead of
focusing on where we want to be
and where we want to head and so
when you focus on negative stuff
not being overweight not being a crappy
dad
not being a always a late employee
right that may be me um
your brain focuses on negative things
and you basically become a highway road
repair person
right instead of focusing on
i want to be the most productive
i want to be the most collegial i want
to be the teammate at work that people
count on
i want to be a guy who is healthy and
able to roll around on the floor with my
great grandkids when i'm a hundred
and the decisions i'm making now about
fitness and about nutrition
and about mental health are going to pay
in
to that vision right i'm gonna live
towards something
then you are not a highway repairman you
are a
architect you're a highway designer
you're an engineer you're something
that's building something for the future
here
and so i think when you talk about how
to change your your format that has to
do with painting a picture of where you
want to go
and not getting pinterest quotes not
getting the latest whatever ad or
whatever
slogan on top of a subway right that's
not it
it is painting a picture of what am i
going to look like when i'm healthy
what am i going to look like when i'm
physically fit what am i going to look
like what is the picture of a good dad
going to look like
it's gonna be me in my front yard
playing catch with my son
with my daughter on my shoulders while
she's trying to tackle me to the ground
and we are laughing and we are carrying
on and we are rolling around in the
grass and we're being goofy and then it
starts raining and we don't go inside
it's all of those things all at once
that's a picture of a good dad for me of
somebody who's played their money card
right and
there's going to be money in the bank
for my kids go to college
there's going to be money in the bank
for them if my son decides to go the
military that
i'm going to have a house for him when
he's out right because i've i've
taken care of my business on the front
end i'm going to be able to play with my
grandkids i'll be able to get in the
floor and get back up and get back in
the floor and get back up
because i exercise all the time and i
take care of my nutrition
that's what it's like man so vladimir's
is a great a great question
i want to challenge everybody to stop
focusing on the bad stuff that you want
to be different
and start focusing on where you want to
go and how you're going to attain that
this stuff goes by the wayside
it goes by the wayside i heard this
great analogy
the baseball players when they're
getting a slump and they're struggling
with
their swing they used to go watch tape
of their slump how bad their swings were
and then they realized that it was just
self-reinforcing the bad swings and so
then they go back now what they do is
they go back and look at
swings that from when they were killing
it
and sometimes a swing shift is an inch
right it's a tiny little trajectory this
way
and so it refocuses the good stuff in
their heads it's focusing on where you
want to be not what you want to get away
from right
so that's my thought there vladimir
thank you so much for that email man
that's excellent
let's go right back to the phone let's
go to brit in fort worth texas
brit good morning how we doing
good morning john thank you for taking
my call
um i'm kind of going through a tough
tough
a difficult time right now because me
and my husband are now going through the
process of divorce
i hate that for you i'm so sorry and
it's kind of like
right now it's like we're now able to
talk to each other now
where we can talk now i guess because
the word marriage is not kind of on the
table anymore
but it's like trying to move forward so
it's like how do you rebuild yourself
once coming from this situation like
because it's
it's my feelings are going back and
forth like divorce or no divorce
and we have four kids together so it's
like do i need to really go forward with
this or do i need to
just go stay the stay the path and just
go ahead and divorce
and you know let bygones be bygones
so one of my general rules is this is
i'm never going to tell somebody
except in rare situations that you need
to go get divorced right now
okay that's a that's a trauma that is a
deep life change that shouldn't be taken
lightly and
some knucklehead on the radio shouldn't
pop off and recommend that
but i will ask a couple of questions and
and help you
walk me through where you're where
you're at the first thing is you said
you're in the process so have you filed
on him or has he filed on you where
what does that mean you're in the
process it's it's we've both said that
we
we we want a divorce okay but then it's
like we neither one of us have actually
went and took that extra
step to go down and file so why do you
want a divorce why did you tell your
husband you're you know what it's time i
want a divorce
he's not loving me the way he needs to
love me like i love him more than
he probably can love me and i put him
before everything else
and he has controlling behavior he's
he's a narcissist and
it's getting to the point now like where
you're locking me out of my phone
you're basically keeping me away from my
friends and family
it's it's gotten to that point where now
i've
given excuses to you for years and now
it's
it's gotten to the point now it's we
have four kids i have three boys
and i don't want my sons growing up
thinking that this is the kind of
behavior that you're supposed to display
to a woman
um gotcha and then we have a daughter
and i don't want my daughter to think
that this is how a man's supposed to
treat you when she gets to that age of
dating
so you just rattled off some things that
you're worried about your kids
and i think those are noble and i think
this idea of
setting examples putting out models for
your kids to follow is critical and
super important but right now i want to
talk about you
you said that you don't think he loves
you like he's supposed to
be more specific for me you said he's
locking you out of your phone
he changes your password on your phone
yeah
what are some other ways well he
constantly accuses me of
of cheating and i'm i mean there's no
reason to do it
but i mean he served in the military and
he's
been vulnerable so there's no telling of
what it could possibly be
or what is going on are you safe
yes are you emotionally safe
no explain that
i'm not i'm not emotionally faced
because
because of what's going on like i can't
be vulnerable with him i can't open up
and say
what's on my what's on my mind and
what's going on
without feeling the fear of judgment or
feeling like he's gonna throw it to the
wayside
because i went through four pregnancies
with him and
i had postpartum depression really bad
and you know you really need that
connection and you need someone there
to give you that assurance and i wasn't
able to get that assurance have you and
him
want to see a counselor together have
you ever gone to talk to somebody at
your local church or a couple that you
trust
is to say hey what's going on how come
no why not
he's got a psych degree and it's kind of
like he's got that
he's got that whole i i have the
psychology degree and i know
what they're going to say and i know how
they feel and that's what it is
kind of mentality what about you have
you gone to see somebody
i've spoken to a lot of different people
and everybody's basically you know
everybody
has their own type of opinion of how to
approach this going forward no no i'm
not talking about just a bunch of
random people i'm talking about have you
gone to a counselor yourself
i did when i was going through
postpartum depression but i did not talk
to them about my marriage or anything
okay brit i think before you do anything
you need to go sit down with a
professional with someone that
is skilled and talking about marriages
that is skilled in
um helping people walk through
what your next steps should be and that
you can really
dig into your relationship your four
kids and what your future
might or might not look like um you owe
that to yourself
you deserve brit i want you to hear me
are you hearing me
yes you deserve to be well
you're a mom of four beautiful babies
three knucklehead little boys and a
beautiful little girl
and you deserve to be a fully whole
mom something here doesn't sound right
to me
something here sounds a little bit i
i just imagine if we sat down for an
hour or two there'd be a whole lot more
to this story so this is one that's just
hard to unwind in 10 minutes or 15
minutes on a radio call
and that's why i'm i'm just going to
plead with you to go
speak with somebody i wish wish
wish your husband would too my guess is
he's got a long story to tell as well
and that he's dealing with his own
challenges
and he would benefit greatly from having
an environment where he could be
vulnerable and talk to people what's
going on
but there is a lot lot here
backing out 30 000 feet here's my my
couple of words on divorce
first thing is you got four kids a
divorce
is going to be a major life change for
y'all
and so again it's not something to be
taken lightly it's not something just to
ask
random people at a bingo hall or at a
church
or at the grocery store this is
something to be taken very very
seriously
the second thing is is there is
something in your voice that makes me
wonder
what wholeness looks like what safety
looks like
and i want you to find a professional
and i also want you to find a mentor
an older woman who maybe has been down
this road before in your community that
you can just sit down
not in a flyby but someone's going to
spend a couple hours with you that you
can sit down and just
let all this out and talk that can be a
guiding light for you divorce is no joke
but being in an unsafe
relationship is no joke either for
everybody out there
struggling with this idea of should i
get divorced should i not
it feels like everybody does it right it
feels like this real
common thing you know you hear the stats
thrown around one out of two
one out of three whatever the numbers
happen to be on whatever given
internet article pops up here's the
thing
we hear it so often that we think it's
just this easy thing to do and it's
not divorce is hard it is
a loss i tell people to treat it like
the death of somebody
and it's sometimes harder than a death
because the person's not dead
you can't fully grieve them being gone
because they're still there and if you
have four kids
you're still gonna have a relationship
with them for the foreseeable future
right so get some wisdom in your life
get a professional get a friend
and thanks for the call brit thanks for
being vulnerable and being open
but you are right you need to go talk to
somebody i can hear it in your voice and
call me back when you make some
decisions i'd love to hear where your
next steps are going to go
and if we can help you man make the next
crooked wobbly step
as you figure out what's next so let us
know how things are going
um we're going to go to laura in phoenix
arizona laura
good morning good morning how are we
doing
good morning john thanks for taking my
call thank you for calling in how can i
help
yeah i'm hoping to just gain some
insight and possible direction on how to
um navigate a marriage relationship with
a person who has adhd
oh i feel like you're um typecasting me
here that i may or may not have that
myself
yeah i mean it's all of it's tricky
because with all the adhd things that i
love most
about him and that's why we fell in love
he just has so much
enthusiasm and such a big heart and he's
so much fun
um i i got divorced from a previous
marriage
and have two kids that i have primary
custody of and he just jumped right in
and no hesitation just wrapped his arms
right around them and it's just been
such a good fun dab for them
um there's just so many things about the
adhd and just who he is as a person that
i love
but now as time's gone on over the
i didn't really understand adhd and its
full effect on adults
and relationships and we've kind of just
been unknowingly playing into
what i'm learning now as a pretty
classic toxic relationship dance between
a non-adhd and an untreated adhd partner
excellent so so explain some of the
things you are learning
they're probably gonna sound a lot like
my home go ahead
yeah well there's there's a lot of that
parent child dynamic where i kind of
just take on
the majority of the load for our family
being the responsible one and the person
that follows through and has that
executive functioning
and um i have been diagnosed with
complex ptsd which makes
which lends me towards being the more
over functioning kind of controlling
partner
okay and so it's been easy for us to
kind of just get stuck in that dance
where i'm trying
to where i'm trying to boss them around
and remind them to do all of these kind
of just basic adult things
right does this play a pretty a pretty
significant
put a pretty significant strain on your
intimate life
yes yes a huge a huge turn on that for
sure
it makes it really hard for me to feel
like i'm in a partnership with or that
i'm like romantically
attracted to him when i feel like he's
just my third kid yeah i was going to
say
one of the the challenges that folks in
this type of
relationship struggle with is to just
put it out there
nobody wants to be intimate with their
mom and nobody wants to be intimate with
their kid
and the longer this goes the more that
golf those relationships get redefined
and yeah did you struggle with this in
your previous marriage
no my previous marriage was just um and
it was an abusive situation i had to
just get out
to protect myself from my kids so it was
definitely different
so you you ran um and i don't mean that
negatively but you ran into the arms
of someone who was the exact opposite
who
is almost has no filter on the
relational engagement part of his brain
who is all
in all the time and more importantly who
let you
have the driver's seat in this time
right in this relationship
you got to drive you get to be the boss
you get to be mom and
that sounds so fun for the screaming
fearful part of your relational brain
that was in an
abusive relationship and now it's
way too much right no fun yeah exactly
and i was just that single mom that was
juggling all the plates by myself and
was used to doing everything and he just
kind of slid in and was like see this is
great and comfy and
you're thanks i'm realizing wait i'm
doing everything and there's a perfectly
capable adult right here who's not
yeah yes okay so how can i help
specifically in your situation
yeah i'm just hoping to get some tips
and guidance on how we can best navigate
it moving forward so we don't just get
stuck in a toxic spiral where we're
just struggling to get along with each
other and struggling to remain attracted
to each other and those kinds of things
what are
what are some tips as far as that goes i
love it okay so the first thing i want
you to do is this
and i've mentioned his book several
times before
um i've got it here i'm gonna hold it up
man i brought this today this is just
couldn't be more extraordinary timing
here this is a book called scattered by
gabor mate
last name m-a-t-e and it's a
first-person narrative a science book
it's the best book on
adhd relationships and being in a
relationship with someone with adhd
i've ever come across in my life it is
a hard read and i mean hard not
difficult but hard
emotionally it's been hard for my wife
to read it was hard for me going through
it one day when my kids read it they're
gonna have a hard time with it
and when i recommend it to people it's
hard here's why
add is not an illness in the medical
sense
right it is it drives me crazy when it
turns into a medical issue and because
we've
developed some medication that that
helps it a little bit
um we think it's it's a disease we think
it's a
medical dysfunction and it's not adhd
mate says it is a it's not a fixed
inherited brain disorder it's
a set of physiological biological
consequences
of an environment of behavior that's
allowed
and chaos right and so here's the thing
is your husband on medication of any
kind no he's not doing anything to treat
it right now
okay um that's fine and i usually
recommend medication as
a second or third or fourth option
um i don't mean to be graphic here but
medicine for adhd is a stop gap it can
be like
diarrhea medication can stop the
explosions right
it's not going to fix your core stomach
issues
what medication can do is help somebody
focus but that focus is only good
if they are using it to develop new
relational skills and really at the end
of the day
a person with adhd struggles with this
idea of
impulse control it's grown people acting
like children because they never
developed it's a developmental disorder
right
it's literally disordered thoughts for
folks who are listening to this
um think of it this way dr mate gives
this great example
all the thoughts are traveling down a
highway and
there's a police officer there who is
stopping traffic coming this way and
he's waving it on just like a traffic
stop
for somebody with an adhd mind it's not
that their thoughts are out of control
it's just that the policeman is just
sitting down letting traffic go so they
all get in the same place at the same
time
which you know adhd medication is really
a stimulant
they fire your brain up and it helps
reorder some things that doesn't sound
like somebody with adhd would need a
stimulant but it helps reorder helps get
that policeman back where they need to
be and they are directing traffic in the
right way
and so as we talked about man no mom
wants to hook up with their son no son
wants to hook up with their mom
right this change does not start well
it starts with you some but this change
really starts with your husband
your husband has to get exhausted with
being exhausted
now this is me this is the pot talking
to the kettle on this one okay
there had to be um a time in my life
when i just had to say enough is enough
is enough adhd
is a context not an excuse
what does that mean that means that
people with adhd often struggle with
magical time
time doesn't exist or i have to be at
work at 10 minutes it's a 30 minute
drive and i'm hopping into the shower at
9 55.
the fact that it's not 10 yet i got
plenty of time the people who work with
me here on this show
they'll know that does that sound like
something at your house oh yeah
so um hey you know what it's fine if the
kids just stay up until midnight tonight
to watch this movie
and twinkies have some nutritional value
we're going to be fine mom we're going
to be fine
and it will all work out tomorrow and
there is this magical
consequence-free environment that folks
live in here's the deal
that's not reality and that's not true
and a person with adhd has the ability
to know that that's not true
what they have to do is create go as far
as they can upstream
and create systems and context and
behavior change
in themselves that starts with this idea
that he is worth
being loved most people with adhd come
from places
of either chaotic environments or they
come from environments where people
withheld
there was neglect there were people that
that didn't teach them
ways to live and love sometimes it's
when people take care of when parents
take care of all of their stuff for
their kids
sometimes it's when parents take care of
none of their stuff for their kids and
kids are constantly constantly
constantly living in chaotic
environments but he's got to
learn to love himself and when he learns
to love himself then he learns that he
is worth
parenting himself and that begins with
cleaning up external chaos
you know cleaning environments being on
time um
you know getting sleep good nutrition
but all that stuff you don't eat right
if you don't think you're worth it
you don't sleep right if i'm just
another guy
right and that's when you come in
it starts with you sitting down or your
your part of this starts with you
sitting down with him and saying
i'm done being your mom i'm your wife
i'm in love with you
romantically i'm not cleaning up after
you i'm not getting you out of bed
anymore
and if you get fired and you can't hold
the job i'm gonna have to protect my
kids from a bad example
and i'm going to have to implement some
measures and that may be
us not being together that may be us um
having to separate for a time until you
you are taking care of yourself but i
can't have my kids picking up and
learning
more chaos because that's how adhd gets
passed along it's not passed
on genetically it's passed on
environmentally there is a genetic
component but
um does that make sense yeah that makes
a lot of sense what
what what do you say is the best way to
kind of help him get
because i think um it really is comorbid
that adhd
with kind of a feeling of learned
helplessness and depression like no
matter how hard he tries he just keeps
failing
and what he's really struggling to never
help yeah it plays into itself right so
then you
you fail at a bunch of stuff you get
fired from a job because you don't show
up on time
and on the way home you stop at four
different fast food restaurants because
you don't care about your nutrition
and then you have eight diet cokes
before you go to bed which means you
don't sleep which means the whole cycle
starts over again right
and yeah then you spin out and the only
way an adhd person
and i'm speaking generally here there's
going to be somebody out there with it
going that's not my case
well congratulations what most people
the way you turn the alarms off
is through hugs through connection
through excitement and novelty right
and so there are probably some pretty uh
wild romantic nights you all have had am
i fair
oh yeah yeah and it's incredible and it
actually makes up for a lot of times
when
the dishes aren't yeah right so they can
be the best
lovers and the best friends
and god almighty they are a beating to
live with and again this is me
this is the pot talking to kettle here
so yeah
what your husband needs to do is this
you all need to number one have you sat
down and had a real hard conversation
with him yet
oh yeah we've had i mean we've had kind
of gentle nudges over the last year of
me being like hey
this is this is hard for me to live with
why don't you go get some treatment
you know and just this last week it
really just like came crashing down like
a bunch of bricks and i was like i
cannot
live with this long term or i'm gonna go
crazy
i'm already getting depressed and i need
you to go get
help i love you i love you for who you
are but in like a romantic relationship
i need this to be a partnership and i
can't
i can't be so unequal all the time and i
need you to go get help where i can't do
this anymore
and so what i want to challenge you to
do is you all go get help
yeah because adhd is healed through
connection
it's healed through other people and
it's healed through
lessening the chaos and that's not
something that people can do by
themselves
and i know that's hard on you because
the whole thing you want is him just to
act like
a grown-up and he needs to act like a
grown-up and i'm living proof
you can act like a grown-up um i've got
my days
oh god almighty i've got my days right
um i struggle with that but
you can act like a grown-up and you can
hold a job and you can decide i'm going
to eat right and sleep right so that the
next morning i wake up refreshed and i
can be in control of my executive
functioning
and i can over time develop from a child
to an adult i can do all those things
they take practice and they take
connection and so um
a couple of things like we talked about
throughout this college want to wrap
this up
and and really put a bow on this i want
you and your husband to
get together and read this book
scattered together by dr
mate i want you to have a off-site i
want you to take him out of your house
i want you all to go take him out of
your house take him out of y'all's house
i want you to go to lunch go to
breakfast
i want you to tell them you're not doing
well and this is not a blow up time this
is a quiet time this isn't in the heat
of
some exchange or yet another time he
didn't pick a socks up or whatever
and i want you to tell me you love him
that he is worth being loved
he is worth being connected to and that
he does not have the skills to be
connected and that you
and him you want to go with him to a
marriage counselor
who specializes in adhd and there are a
bunch of them
and i want you to walk with him through
this journey
for as long as you can it may be that
medication is necessary if he's if he's
25
35 45 and he's never wrestled with this
sometimes medication can really help
i've had a buddy of mine a couple of
buddies of mine
who in their 40s and 50s took medication
for the first time and they said it was
like being in a crowded stadium
and someone just turned the noise down
and they didn't know it they
one of them wept as he told me about it
he said i've never could have imagined
it and by having the volume of the
stadium turned down
then he can finally listen to his wife
and be in connection with her
and that's the medication good it's not
a long-term solution it's not gonna fix
you but it will give you it may give you
some space to go learn some new skills
or your husband to go learn some new
skills
um counseling for disconnection learn
how to be a relationship nutrition
exercise sleep sleep sleep getting out
into nature
playing just enjoying life right
but learning how to do it in the right
times all of these are fixes all of
these are ways to
help a i don't use the word fix i want
to back up all of these are ways to help
somebody with adhd develop into
an adult mind a responsible mind it is a
process
it's an adventure and it's a journey but
if you hear nothing else adhd is
not a disease it does not have to be the
rest of your life
and you can fix it you can't cross it
fix again
people i'm trying not to say fix we're
not machines you can
develop and grow up i'm i'm testament
here i'm proof of it
i held a day job and i showed up to work
on time i even shut up early today
with my work prepared and you can too
thank you so much for the call laura
thank you so much for everybody calling
today
and hey i want to end with the song
lyrics of the day the greatest
the greatest the greatest songwriter of
all time the greatest like
this woman inspired my soul when i was
in college
oh my goodness just thinking about this
song makes
makes my eyes water a little bit makes
my heart beat a little bit faster this
is a
song about love this is a song about
separation it's a song about
the gulf between two people it's from
the 1992
classic little earthquakes by the
greatest song
writer of all time tori amos this is her
song china
it goes like this china all the way to
new york
i can feel the distance getting close
you're right next to me
but i need an airplane i can feel the
distance as you
breathe and sometimes i think you want
me to touch you
well how can i when you build a great
wall around you
in your eyes i saw a future together ah
but you just look away into the distance
tori i can feel the distance i can feel
the distance getting close
tori don't give up on you and i won't
give up on you either
this is the dr john dalone's show